buonasera
allora io sono luciano cantini e sono il
cofondatore dickens trapper che è
un'azienda familiare e fiorentina che si
occupa di produzione progettazione e
vendita di stampanti tridimensionali
dico familiare perché c'è stata fondata
nel 2011 da me e mio fratello e da
nostro padre per poi in seguito essere
estesa anche ad altri membri della
nostra famiglia come i miei cugini mio
zio è il nostro nonno che ci aiuta nelle
nella pole nella pulizia delle parti
plastiche costituiscono le stampanti
stesse e nel corso degli anni è stata
estesa anche a eventuali collaboratori
esterni che ci aiutano nella ricerca e
nello sviluppo
tornando alle stampanti e
tridimensionali
esse sono macchine in grado di
riprodurre con buona precisione un
oggetto fisico come queste le tengo in
mano ma anche altri a partire da un loro
modello tridimensionale
l'oggetto in questione viene realizzato
attraverso la sovrapposizione di tanti
strati e a seconda della modalità con
cui vengono realizzati registrati si
possono avere diverse tipologie di
stampanti dimensionali si possono avere
stampanti che utilizzano blocchi di
resine o polimeri fotosensibili
solidificate attraverso fasci di luce
ultravioletta o puntatori laser si
possono avere stampanti a polveri come
si utilizza un latro granulare o
comunque un letto di polvere fatto
indurire ho sempre con del laser oppure
con degli inchiostri agglomerante
particolari oppure si possono avere
stampante a tecnologia fdm in cui si va
a depositare strati di materiale fermo
fuso il nostro modello tridimensionale
infatti il software effetto a quello che
viene definito slicing un affettamento
del modello ovvero si passò dividerlo in
tanti strati differenti e poi si va a
ricostruirlo
spostando uno strato sopra l'altro il
modello da cui si parte in particolar
modo può essere realizzato o da un
qualsiasi software cad tridimensionale
quindi tramite un vostro computer oppure
può essere scaricato gratuitamente da
internet e da uno dei tanti siti alcuni
esempi di applicazione di questa
tecnologia possono essere quello
industriale anche in ambito meccanico
per realizzare componenti meccanici
funzionanti
oppure per realizzare anche strumenti
campo archeologico per realizzare delle
copie di reperti archeologici come
teschi e crani o anche denti in quel
caso di squali preistorici in campo
artistico per replicare ad esempio delle
copie di monumenti o di statue ancora ad
esempio possono essere utilizzati in
campo architettonico per realizzare
plastici e nel campo industriale per
realizzare prototipi di vasi di calici
di giocattoli di statuine ancora ad
esempio in campo medico possono essere
utilizzati per realizzare protesi
dentali repliche di organi o un campo
chimico per realizzare l'esempio per
rendere visibile quindi a livello
macroscopico gli atom che costituiscono
le molecole che sul primo aspetto è
molto importante perché può essere
utilizzato in campo didattico per
mostrare agli studenti come sono fatte
le molecole e soprattutto avvicinarle
appunto in maniera divertente al mondo
della chimica o della medicina ancora
utilizza i più particolari possono
riguardare il campo della moda dove
invece possono essere utilizzati per
realizzare vestiti o accessori come
borsette scarpe o ancora nel campo della
musica per realizzare dei prototipi di
strumenti musicali
per concludere il campo o meglio i campi
della stampante tridimensionale sono
infiniti il limite fondamentalmente la
fantasia dell'utilizzatore del creativo
e possono addirittura essere utilizzate
in ambito domestico per effettuare
piccole riparazioni andando allungare il
tempo di vita quindi di un oggetto
contribuendo quindi anche dal punto di
vista dell'impatto ambientale poiché si
utilizzano generalmente materiali o
riciclabili
oppure biodegradabili con questo
concluso grazie dell'attenzione